no I have time for that one-minute war
zone rated 63 players 1812 is the
average rating time handicap 30-minute
let's roll
William B we have played before and
what's the clock situation okay my thing
was showing 21 minutes this thing for a
split second and then it went back up to
regular efore and know what Bishop c4
target f7 quickly maybe I should go with
an early Bishop c4 Knight g5 stuff I
think that that could catch a lot of
people I should have played d4 may be
annoying pin 95 take the bishop Oh a
shattered structure and on the Queen
resignation time might be resignation
time what do we have back to tournament
- Oh who's in the lead let the
tournament end right now okay a lot of
time so far so good a quick win is good
okay let's roll here get that night out
of there get the night out and then run
the H pun get out of there Knight
let's go H pun let's roll
Oh Oh reorganization Queen here right
here and just in the nick of time h 2 h
2 h 2 h 2 the rook has to move I don't
even know what I have yes I have each -
I do know what I have okay 600 that was
a quick win Todorov ik the wolf not the
same as wolf man for those of you that
are familiar with the wolf man the guy
that beat me with just a point one
seconds remaining a game I still have
nightmares about oh let's queenside
castle now let's not let's play here
look for tricks h7 not quite I'm
hang on to that pond now uh-oh h7 h7 h7
Oh they sniffed that one out they
sniffed it out
okay let's try for a quick me they're
gonna see it let's go here dark square
weaknesses dark squares pileup censored
Center what am I saying
censure censure what is censure that's a
new term you're familiar with censure
I'm not I don't even know what it means
Center centralize your pieces that's
what I meant to say centralized push
your H pun uh why do I can't it be
easier okay let's come here g5 is on no
it's not stay active
get out of there clean back rank mater's
kill the Queen the queen is dead dead
Queen resign this is beat I'm okay on
the on the clock
don't be a time burner there being a
time burner check check and then there's
no back ranked me that would be bad that
would be very bad
this is mate this is mate this is mate
back to tournament 12 woo the first one
to get double digits got three games in
I could get beat any second though okay
they're going for this and I'm gonna
launch all my pawns not all of them but
many of them let's open this up open
this up how do you open it up let's go
open this up okay is this working open
it up please my LightSquared bishop
wants to do something okay let's get the
light squared bishop soph and get to
this h3 square and then follow up with
Knight g5 actually I'm gonna do this
right away I'm looking for this fork um
okay let's take care and then my rook
doing something my knight wants to do
something as well
rook up and over
look up and then over Oh serious
problems serious problems for me oh I
gotta watch out for that fork Oh pin
city pin City the queen is dead and then
Queen right here could be pre moved
unless the bishop plays there okay back
to chairman 20 oh I got two are you I
got four games in who's this all right
let's roll no we got the fishing pole
type of positions okay maybe not maybe
still actually hang on
oh they're kicking my night away but now
I have possibilities for local majority
I'm the clean side ah okay now there's
d6 and stuff actually night at 5:00 oh
they got that pond give a check get that
clean out of there
don't castle actually I got the bishop
there's there wouldn't be oh ooh ooh ooh
get that Bishop can't that Bishop Queen
here I have a fork go here it's safe
Queen right here you know you want to do
that it's very safe oh just take the
knight it's okay to do that discover
checks this is bean this is definitely
beat I'm on the Queen I really don't
want to clean trade but we're not gonna
have a Queen trade or are we know they
can block ah who gets the last laugh on
that one actually I do
come on peace is everywhere oh there's
pins and queens and pawns a6 kill the
Queen develop your rooks Bishop f4 give
a check the King is running out of
squares Queen here no matter what mate
coming up here the rook will defend I
deflect maid threat that's me that's me
back to tournament 30 16 12 12 oh I
don't like having people chased me from
behind
let's go Jonathan cm c5 Jonathan's out
uh where we at what's the scoop here Oh
quick respecter 42
20:16 a quick resigner i'll take some
quick reasons in this tournament I'd
have any in the last tournament none
nada
ah okay let's go and launch an H pun
o light squared Bishop is out of here
has left the scene so what do you do Oh
Oh Queen b3 hitting at two weak points
f7 the weakest point in town and b7 Oh
King here have a knight
oh this is a killer rook takes is bad
the Queen has to take oh the queen is
dead dead Queen uh-oh this is close to
me no this is better
is there mate no just get the Queen I
get everything now the king is running
for the hills
uh-oh this is a fork Forks actually okay
now there isn't a mate there where are
you going King this is mate come on
where's the main a check no just right
here I guess what does that mean okay
there's got to be made real soon a pawn
push next that's working back to turn 56
56 26 2020s okay a lot of twenties there
Oh
22 minutes we're only eight minutes in
and I have seven games and that is a lot
of games not complete games of course
but okay games nevertheless that I got
some points for open Sicilian Quincy
seven you've seen it before see it again
oh let's try it or not h 2 is not on or
maybe it is still i want to get some
more development i want to keep my queen
here maybe push a couple times and oh I
shouldn't have done that let's play here
actually Bishop here and then get rid of
the dark square Bishop no right here
good spot I think look here King up
stuff that tells me King up might be a
good idea maybe not why did I do that
this my queen is in a good spot g5 to
preserve my clean position okay we're
gonna have a bunch of trades aren't we
rook right here okay hello I don't have
a support point now I should plead no
Queen trade can we have a queen trade
please oh yes it's forced because I get
the night the night is pin no it's not
I want my knight on c5 I don't see five
get that pawn past pawn position good
night versus bad bishop I have dark
square control darker control my knight
wants to be on this square now and my
king wants to be on c4 where's that
Bishop going my bishop wants to be on c6
actually I want to be over in a
different spot right here after that
pond and then King King position sneak
my king in do not fall for anything
sneaky here if there's a check okay hit
this bishop actually take my knight good
versus bad Bishop position now I got
this pawn okay this just pushed my pawn
now just keep going just run run run run
oh they're gonna try to be sneaky
another knife back to tournament 7250
2:30
oh it's tight less than 20 the assassin
everybody should fear the assassin okay
Knight f6 oh okay Tosh okay isolate a
queen pawn now let's change the
structure actually and get my queen side
majority now rolling and my opponent is
having something to say about that not
so quick they say pin the night if the
position opens up it's uncomfortable to
be in a pin be aware of that it's
uncomfortable to be in a pin or it's
uncomfortable to be in an open position
when you're having to deal with the pin
should follow that Knight a5 2 B 3 B 3
is a weak point if I could just move
them ah stupid Mouse okay let's go here
my knight is defending B
seven let's hit a rook you can't be too
happy you have to watch out for age
seven let's get get rid of that threat
I'm also allowing my poem to get out of
a pin now I can get him b5 well he could
have done that sooner okay realizing
that it's probably a strong night right
there they're doing an exchange sack I
want to get him b5 recapture with my
queen it's a good post I'd like to get
here because it's hitting the knight and
controlling the flight squared on g2 so
let's simplify this how can we simplify
this put on push here similar to a
previous position I had in the stream
okay I really oh I could take this the
bishop is pinned I'm gonna take that
they're probably gonna go here are they
or not haha okay let's go King you want
to play you still want to play and you
want to get even more active actually I
should have just taken that bishop and
then run my pawn he can't be caught he's
a fast pond wrong with them he was a
fast pawn
let's come over here and get this guy he
needs help and he doesn't have any help
they forfeit on time back to tournament
ninety seventy five forty five ten games
oh this is a big game this is a big game
if I could just move quick Oh chopper
ruski pin ruski what are we having oh
this guy's in second I should recaptured
the pond and worked on isolated Queen
pond position take that Oh what are we
gonna have here I want to get rid of the
night maybe can I get rid of the night I
want to get on that square can I defend
defense oh I get to see five maybe like
right here defend the pawn Knight right
here had a defense stuff am i defending
stuff my defending Brook right here
Queen right here Queen right here won
one of these squares triple up right
here um let's go with this one and then
pile up here triple up on this pond
right here do I have it have enough
pieces on it what's the clock situations
pretty even
right oh I'm on the rook is my opponent
gonna move I need some help my knight
need some help
my knight need some help help fork
my name is going astray oh he needs some
help and he's not getting any help help
for guru ski I'm gonna take it
trade let's just trade please trade I
just want some trades give me with the
trades this is a big win come on defend
defend don't you dare lose this
don't you dare Queen trades Queen trade
uh-oh big trouble big trouble I got this
one I got it don't you dare Mouse lip
don't you dare try to get active okay
sneak over here sneak over here King
position King position King position
rook position run pawn rook no
stalemates don't you dare pawn move
right here right here sneak over one two
three win two three yes a clutch win
that was big I'm gonna take the big wins
oh okay double up double those points
that was important okay let's go knight
c6 Queen c7 no I got a bishop Queen to
b6 two points F to be to weakened Oh
matin one if the king goes to wrong
square where's he gonna go let's check
in the round no I didn't check him
around
what's this cleanup - let's give check
get the rook oh I have this defendant by
my bishop I'm on the rook
I got g7 defended got the real-time on
the knight trouble oh come on this is
resigned time isn't it got the night
free of charge back to tournament they
resigned 130 130 73 72 less than 15
minutes double those points let's roll
here Bishop c4
go for a quick kill they would see that
I was gonna play queen h5o dropping a
pawn maybe or not hang on let's get out
of this before there's a problem are
they gonna sack they might sack right
there it could be a nasty pin and it is
okay
Oh why'd I let the knight get there okay
they had an opportunity for a knight
right here oh man let's come over here I
need to get out of this pin over here oh
it's scary it's very scary over here
okay the mates right I have a main
threat can you believe that Queen trade
I'm on the bishop as well I think they
thought they might have been removing
defender by that with that move right
here no I wanted my knight to go there
bishop is that are stupid I want to take
that pawn or h6 I can't take what my
King otherwise it's good a fork let's
play here and then double up right here
they might throw a check in I could
defend this point with my row come on G
2 and G 6 does not defend this is a
check where is the main I don't want to
I actually don't want to do that let's
do this I don't think there might be
problems over here if they did that
let's defend throw on a check or maybe
not I'm on the rope they might have
suspected a check let's throw it in for
fun and then take the rook no time
they're down on time and position back
to tournament 150 151 33 Capra is not
going away
why isn't he going away I thought I'd
beat him and he's still around get out
of there get out of second place okay
let's roll here Quincy 7 Knight f6
fishing pole and fishing pole fishing
poles everywhere take tonight I'm gonna
take tonight Oh H - give me that H 2
square 170 133 12 minutes and change oh
man was that an on purpose somebody do
that one on purpose maybe I might be
able to get a
I shouldn't have gone for this variation
the pawn takes pawn with check and well
I guess we're gonna enter something a
bit quiet aren't we
or maybe well now a fishing pole is too
far fetched in this case take that pawn
maybe get out of this pin before it's
too late
okay the Knights gonna be a pain it's
clearly a pain and I can't take with the
Queen otherwise the rooks have too much
fun I don't want them to have fun okay
now let's come here King position King
position is definitely needed and who is
this guy this is um 2500
what's a 2500 doing in here that's crazy
pins pins take my bishop repair my pawns
what did i do what did i do what did i
okay finally repair those pawns pigs on
the seventh king position rook position
keep the king boxed out get out of there
King I don't want to look trade okay
actually I'm come over here this isn't
so great or maybe it is get my other
pawns going I somehow get my other pawns
going Brooke is gonna get real active
get out of there King okay that was a
good move can I get to the seventh Can I
grab one pond and then come back to
defend grab one pond or maybe two and
then come back to defend come up let's
go after this guy connect to past ponds
if I get this one over here quickly
don't stop me King get these other guys
going
avoid deflections by telford deflections
what's the clock home oh okay we're
gonna have this I want to check them
around a little bit check
go check happy okay they're gonna go
check happy on me no I got them maybe
check check right here I have more time
than them when we got more checks I'm
gonna get that pawn pawn push
you've checked to me check here watch
out for the discoveries watch out for
the discoveries we have this is
definitely a draw avoid the rook
exchange at all costs check anything
burn the time clock burner got it Oh
19130 one less than ten let's go no not
that far not that far don't you dare yes
a quick resigner 201 31 did kappa rot
fall back I'm playing against their
granola bar oh the granola bar the
granola bar my favorite player right
here my favorite is the granola bar okay
let's get some structural damage and
let's watch out for that III square that
could be a giant pain and so too can
that pun okay take the night all right
and now let's get my queen out here and
then my bishop my bishop wants to play I
might oh there's close to being traps
here mm-hmm okay I got to defend like
this if the knight goes there okay well
that's not happening is it okay uh right
here right here right here right here
right here hit the rook grab this pawn
everything's gonna be okay I think you
have another pawn even stop that
nonsense no I should just take and would
it defend it be - what's the clock like
okay defend these squares okay a trade
here check and a check here Knight
position forks forks where the forks
right here for it's hitting the whole
family everything's going down right
here Bishop Knight rook oh this is
trouble
resigned time is it my opponent
resigning
check what's the clock 18 I got
everything now check defend my knight
watch out for steel me right here stop
the pawn from moving but watch out for
stalemate stop this guy
no stalemates don't you dare try to
steal me don't you dare
FML stalemate check check
that's me that's me back to tournament
to 2138 131 okay less than eight do I
have time to breathe a little bit time
to breathe here we go let's go here
negative
what are we out here oh this might I
might have a breather actually I was
just talking about that can I get a
breather this might be my breather this
guy's giving me a breather right here oh
no I'm just gonna grab some water but
they resigned wait a second what didn't
I didn't I only have two thirty anyhow
they resigned they're to 30 less than
eight minutes still Oh double fianchetto
let's get this F pond in file before
Knight f3 and then Bishop have it
pointing over here the Knights gonna
play to f6 I could get away with this
okay dark square weaknesses Bishop is
dead if it goes to f6 it's dead it's a
dead bishop they have to do a counter
sac right here they have to give to two
minor pieces up I want to I want them to
give up a bishop it's gonna have to
happen real soon
Oh or is it okay what am I missing here
Bishop takes pawn let's come back I was
thinking about taking here that's why I
hesitated clean right here and oh okay
check 55 I don't have 25 seconds let's
get castled queenside castle and they
move the bishop or not I'm on the rook
first mate soon it's a mate maybe okay
where are they gonna Castle okay let's
get the bishop here and then take that
pawn actually I'm not even threatening
that
just move oh my goodness I don't have
any time where is the clock oh I have so
much material but I don't have any time
bishop here okay now I think
everything's gonna be smooth hopefully I
got the Queen let's go okay this is this
is clear now I could give a check check
two diagonals covered right oh this is
leading to mate the rook has to block
that's main yes back to tournament 251
71 156 five minutes and change Oh see
see pots let's go here what is gonna go
on here my opponents not moving they're
not moving and non-moving and now I'm
over here let's go here let's go grab a
deep on open Sicilian land look at H -
no actually that Bishop can't come out
here
my Knights gonna my bishop wants to be
here just to get on the document before
their Bishop gets there they're looking
to grab that pawn Knight to d4 Oh what's
happening with this what's happening
with this forks for concie to come
inside castle they're crazy if they do
that they deal with the hat with the
open B file but BAE Queen b6 move the
knight look for main bishop there's a
fork here I should probably do that
oh the Queen's dead the Knights in a pin
and there's no saving it the rook is
cooked cooked rook variation oh boy rook
is still hit and the pond width check
everything's hit the whole family the
whole family is getting hit right now
let's just take this even though I lose
my queen
no I don't where is the main I have so
much material here just do something
with it
anything anything
rook here get the Queen doing something
give a check that's not check
where is the main cheese just open this
up okay over here makin one to that King
is flying
he's so nuts right there he's fleeing
about crazy King right there to 7201
three minutes and change let's go here I
think I have it sealed that is a lead
right there not always the case if you
are super new you'll know that I was
actually just coming off of taking two
beatings last turtle bit oh I think I
have this one unless something crazy
happens I think I have this one under
control let's go Bishop g5 my bishops
trapped but I don't care I'm going for
this guy uh-oh Bishop takes Bishop
Bishop takes Bishop move move move
Bishop takes Bishop Knight takes pawn
TKO here we go take the bishop it's made
on each seven you know you want to do it
no you don't want to do it okay let's
take here I'm on FF and maybe one day on
push here I'm dead can I just get to
this square please two minutes dropping
stuff don't quit droppin stuff here okay
Queen here can I just get to age six
please quit checking me 95 maybe okay
this I just want to get him out of the
way Queen here Queen age six no get out
of there night get out of there
deflection time get out okay good you're
out now we could get here finally it's
all I want ever wanted g7 or AG one of
the two dark square weaknesses a very
valuable Bishop to be giving up if
you're gonna go a kingside Fein kettle
to ninety to nineteen now twenty games
in which is a lot
one minute fifty-one seconds can I make
it one more game twenty-one okay one
minute forty seconds I need to win with
ten seconds remaining on my clock I have
about thirty seconds to try and win this
one
by force my opponent will always have
the possibility for running their own
clock H 2 H 2 is on H 2 is I'm I got it
can I sneak in one more 310 310 219 one
minute 20
one minute 19 18 17 what do we have one
minute 15 one minute 12 oh no I'd have
to win in like 5 seconds that's not
happening no way okay this is a French
Oh can I get a quick win somehow right
here Knight g5 I can actually do that
and then there's a check oh no no no no
no did I just die either what's a bad
woman
a mouse slipper Oh guess who's gonna
have to do an owner floor and own a fry
maybe wait a second how much time I want
to go flawless hang on
give a check a ruski grab a pawn keep
your rook
grab a knight 30 seconds Oh can I get a
mate somehow don't you dare try and land
a fort oh I'm on h7 be scared I'm on h7
I'm on p7 trouble don't you dare me me
oh how much time only 11 seconds run
King run for the hills over here it's
safe no I just dropped a knight Oh
Forks right here skewers and stuff run
back over here it's safer over here yes
they called it they threw in the towel
that didn't make any sense I got the
first place confetti oh that went way
around I had a mouse slip I dropped my
queen I wanted to take on g6 Oh Saved by
the Bell on that one saved by the clock
alright good games